[Música]
de 20 por favor se pongan de pie vamos a
aguardar los celulares de las bolsitas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno tenga más
calderón pero el pamesa
amarillo pero mire
[Música]
pero no
pero
[Música]
muy bien de su madre
qué bien que se siente hacer ejercicio
después de estar tanto tiempo sentado
verdad verdad que sí es que realmente el
ejercicio es un acto de amor que podamos
hacer con nuestro cuerpo es una
actividad que transforma que cambia las
vidas por un momento quiero que vean sus
piernas toques de las piernas que
fuertes que son ahora nos sirven para
recorrer largas distancias para subir
escaleras para escalar montañas ahora
quiero que me enseñen los bíceps a ver
los bíceps
un poquillo a esos vicios es importante
tener fuerza para levantar a nuestros
hijos animales mascotas los objetos del
supermercado ahora una espalda flexible
y un core fuerte no tienen precio porque
nos dan la habilidad de agachar nos de
girar de movernos extendernos con
libertad ustedes fueron testigos de eso
ahora verdad cuando se estaban moviendo
y ahora también quiero decirles que el
ejercicio cuando se hace a alta
intensidad cuando uno da todo cuando
sale esa zona de confort se libera una
sensación de felicidad tras el esfuerzo
no saca sonrisas
y además aumentamos y mejoramos
inmediatamente muchas cosas por ejemplo
aumentar y mejorar nuestro estado de
ánimo mejora la memoria y la
concentración es que realmente hacer
ejercicio es una herramienta pero
perfecta para estar y mantener en buen
estado está perfecta máquina que es
nuestro cuerpo
y el ejercicio también ayuda no
solamente a nivel corporal ayuda también
al cerebro porque cuando unos ejercicios
se generan ciertos neurotransmisores
como por ejemplo la adrenalina
adrenalina la que se siente no yo aquí
por estar aquí parada porque es la
hormona de la acción ok
también esta misma nos ayuda a generar
dopamina y serotonina pero la serotonina
me interesa mucho que ustedes oigan
porque esa es la hormona que está
relacionada con el estado de ánimo con
el humor con el placer y también dice
que ésta está relacionada con el apetito
sexual udi y dice que cuando estaba en
bajita tendremos a comer más
carbohidratos era cierto que nos tanto
bajamos más por ellos pues puede ser que
si vean a su tiempo escuché así quieren
realmente son un expositor conferencista
y él dijo algo que me llamó sumamente la
atención que la gente últimamente está
utilizando sus cuerpos como el medio de
transporte de sus cabezas como la manera
de llevar los cerebros a las reuniones
es cierto o es en serio la que pasa de
un día pasó una semana pasó un mes pasó
un año y decimos que hicimos por
nosotros
puede ser que estemos viviendo ahora en
algo que yo les llamo la tecnología
liberadora de esfuerzos y es que cada
vez nos gusta todo más automático no nos
gusta hacer filas menos esperar ir a un
banco no jamás ir a comprar al
supermercado no nos conectamos en línea
o pedimos que nos traigan todo a la casa
entonces sucede algo cada vez nos
estamos moviendo menos por eso ocurre un
efecto colateral que es el sedentarismo
o la vida sedentaria según la
organización mundial de la salud gente
el 60 por ciento de la población a nivel
mundial no realiza actividad física
entonces suceden cosas muy tristes
realmente nos estamos quedando en algo
atrás nos estamos quedando aquí en este
sillón sentados así cómodamente con el
control en la mano cumpliendo un ciclo
es levantarse en la mañanita bañarse
bueno algunos yo no sé si nos vamos al
trabajo cuántas horas pasamos montados
en el calor en el tránsito luego
llegamos a la oficina a sentarnos
analicen cuantas horas pasas sentados en
la oficina y si no también en redes
sociales conectados luego volvemos a
cumplir el mismo ciclo otra vez hasta
llegar a la casa y en eso se nos va
facilitó de lunes a viernes y el fin de
semana decimos me merezco descansar
quienes les faltan me merezco comer el
mero escrito al menos traguitos o
quedarme sentado viendo televisión sin
hacer nada y déjenme decirles gente que
los efectos del sedentarismo y de la
actividad física son muchos mira primero
luego la 1 todo se eleva la circulación
baja la circulación también uno está más
débil y también nos da como pereza hacer
las cosas no solamente eso sino hay
asuntos a nivel psiquiátrico
debilitantes como los estados de pánico
la depresión la hipocondría
y el envejecimiento prematuro también el
sobrepeso que es ese exceso de
porcentaje de grasa en el cuerpo sé que
es un montón de cosas y de males que
vienen por defecto de la inactividad y
los a veces estamos tan cansados que
decimos me merezco vacaciones ojalá irme
allá donde no me entre un correo donde
el 91 whatsapp pero yo les quiero
cambiar a usted a la historia qué tal si
hacemos más bien actividad física para
sentirnos mejor salir a caminar a un
parque o leer el aire libre la
naturaleza sacar al perrito a caminar y
también hacer unos cuantos pulsaciones
lagartijas antes de salir al trabajo
también os ayudaría a tener más enfoque
y reacción para enfrentarnos al día a
día vean a gente que cuida más su
automóvil lo quiere tanto más que su
propio cuerpo porque le pone los mejores
aceites cuando ese carro está malito lo
llevan inmediatamente al mecánico cuando
tiene un choque citó así mínimo hay que
llevarlo a arreglar se le enciende una
luz en el dax y sé que será salud pero
cuando el cuerpo nos da alertas a
nosotros
y nos dice él está pasando algo no
hacemos nada esperamos estar muy mal
para ir al médico a quien le ha pasado
eso verdad está uno bien malita y estoy
hasta que ya dice ya voy a ir el cuerpo
humano es también una máquina pero es la
más perfecta que hay porque nada creado
por el ser humano va a poder sobrepasar
está magnificencia de esa estructura de
206 huesos músculos y órganos sabía que
tenemos alrededor de 650 músculos para
ir un poquito más o menos y de los
cuales el 90% son los músculos que
podemos mover los esqueléticos o
voluntarios lo que se le llama la
carnita qué cantidad de músculos que
tenemos que poner en acción cierto
el cuerpo es tan sorprendente a mí me
impresiona que él sabe cuándo se tiene
que levantar cuando se tiene que ir a
dormir se despierta cuando tiene ganas
de ir al baño también regula su propia
temperatura conoce el milagro del
embarazo conoce el milagro del
nacimiento tu corazón nunca se pierde un
latido y tus pulmones nunca dejan de
respirar este el cuerpo sorprendente
realmente es una computadora que no
comete errores
él
[Música]
y ahí está un alimento puedan atención
hay un alimento que se come que nos
nutre pero que nos nutre pero que no se
come a ver hay un alimento que nos nutre
pero que no se come no es una adivinanza
es un concepto que se llama comida
primaria qué es eso en qué consiste
consiste en las relaciones personales
consiste en la carrera profesional en la
actividad física y la espiritualidad
gente ustedes podrán estar comiendo la
mejor comida de este planeta lo más
nutritivo de este mundo pero si no
existen estas cuatro cosas en la vida de
uno hay un desbalance un desequilibrio
quizás no seamos completamente felices y
saben por qué porque nosotros somos
seres integrales que nos movemos en un
mundo muy cambiante y competitivo de la
gente lucha por sus puestos de trabajo
lucha por estar feliz por ser exitoso en
lo que hace y quizás nos estamos dejando
guiar por cosas más superfluas lo que
está de moda y dietas y dejamos aparte
lo que realmente importa
o así algo que realmente importa el
abrazo de alguien que nosotros amamos es
la expresión de cariño que nos hace
tanta falta a veces también estar
felices satisfechos y estar contentos en
nuestros trabajos esas cosas puede hacer
que nos nutra más que una buena comida y
cuando hacemos algo por alguien y sin
esperar recibir nada a cambio esto nos
llena el espíritu también cuando hacemos
una actividad física como bailar cuantas
sonrisas nos puede sacar eso dígame si
eso realmente nos llena la vida de una
persona
bueno el concepto de comida primaria que
les acabo de decir es moderno de sumo
nutrición moderna pero son conceptos son
prácticas que se vienen dando por
décadas en varios lugares en el mundo
voy a citar los blusón que son cinco
lugares particulares a nivel mundial en
donde la gente es muy longeva lo normal
es vivir 80 son chiquillos del 80 y 90 y
100 años ok pero a ellos tienen que
saber que nosotros los chicos debemos
estar orgullosos porque una de esas
zonas está aquí en la península de
nicoya
y a ellos nos caracterizan 9 prácticas
que realizan a diario yo me imagino que
ustedes gustaría saber cuáles son bueno
ellos se mueven de manera natural ellos
como esta señora que ustedes van a ver
aquí se mueven de manera natural son muy
activos ellos reducen el estrés del día
a día reducen la velocidad también son
personas que tienen un propósito claro
en su vida ellos comen hasta quedar a un
80 por ciento satisfechos sea lo justo
nomás su alimentación está basada en
frutas vegetales y mucha agua pero
también se toman su vinito o su traguito
desde anoche uno tiene una fe arraigada
fuerte y además viven con vínculos
familiares muy fuertes y además de
amigos y también pertenecen a la
comunidad adecuada y vean gente si vemos
estas prácticas estas nueve que mencioné
no son cosas que están tampoco es tan
largo de cumplir o tan difícil es verdad
yo creo que es más o menos vivir la vida
como si hoy fuera nuestro último vida
día aquí en la tierra y vivirla con
pasión y hablando de pasión según la
universidad de montreal
dice que al tener sexo por allá pusieron
atención
al tener sexo por 25 minutos o más a una
intensidad 25 minutos con intensidad
promedio los hombres queman siento en
calorías y las mujeres 69 un que
interesante y qué pasaría si a esta
actividad sexual le ponemos más
intensidad y dura más una hora bueno
para aquellos que aguante ahora una hora
no no no digan que ya están levantando
la mano por ahí ok
jaja es que realmente gente la actividad
física está relacionada completamente
con una persona que sea más fuerte más
flexible y que tenga mejor condición
física está totalmente relacionado
porque porque podemos hacer y hacer
ciertas poses sillas ahí que por siete
los quieren personas
esta es de pilates un plan que quien le
ha visto y yoga down dog así que se las
doy como ti para que la ponga en cuenta
hoy la noche tal vez puede ser un buen
día verdad en serio no es que realmente
ayuda muchísimo a la persona hombres
quieren que les diga una cosa el
ejercicio les ayuda muchísimo a evitar
la disfunción eréctil también les ayuda
a aumentar los niveles de testosterona
que por cierto están muy altos entre las
7 a las 8 de la mañana se vale llegar
tarde al trabajo de iu jaja y chicas el
fin de semana no sé me levanté muy tarde
porque si no se va a reducir la
población a nivel mundial
ok a las mujeres el ejercicio nos ayuda
muchísimo a fortalecer los músculos del
piso pélvico porque esto se pueden haber
debilitado después de los embarazos nos
ayuda a evitar la incontinencia urinaria
y también a aumentar el apetito sexual
esto todo esto el ejercicio se posee no
se las enseñé hoy porque mejor otro día
así esto está un poquito difícil
yo a estas alturas me gustaría hacerles
una pregunta ahí viene el punto clave
aquí ustedes creen que nos estamos
dejando deteriorar ustedes están dejando
deteriorar creen que ustedes gustaría
que sus familiares sus nietos sobrinos
lo recuerden por ser una persona que
está sentada en una silla sin poder
valerse por sí misma o les gustaría que
lo recordaran por ser esa mamá abuelito
tío cool que los llevaba a jugar al
parque lleno de energía ustedes creen
que hacer ejercicio ya es como muy tarde
como que ya no es lo mío como que ya no
tengo que hacerlo creo que hay que
pensar muy bien eso no soy yo al menos
cuando estaba pequeñita vea me hizo
gracia a ver esa foto dar me quedé
viendo la foto
a mí me hacían bullying porque yo era
que tenía sobrepeso y con la ayuda de mi
familia y mucha actividad física bien a
lo que me dedico 39 años después es que
me llamó la atención que yo estaba
escondiendo el helado seguro no quería
que me lo vieron
y entonces el punto es que yo era yo
yo pasé por eso y yo yo sé lo que es
vivir haciendo ejercicio y me ha hecho
algo muy bueno en mi vida nosotros
tenemos en esta mano el boleto de la
vida ha asegurado gente el perdón el
vuelto de la muerte asegurado ese es el
que tenemos que todos sabemos que vamos
para allá el boleto de la vida que
tenemos aquí es el boleto que podemos
cambiar
y vean no hay que convertirse un super
profesional con 30 minutos de caminata
al día que usted salga aunque sea pasea
del perro lo que sea o tres veces ir a
entrenar al gimnasio o andar en
bicicleta o correr es suficiente la
salud es el bien más preciado que
nosotros podamos tener porque usted
podrá tener la mejor condición social el
mejor trabajo la mejor familia y mejor
caro casa pero si no tenemos salud no
tenemos casi nada si nosotros somos
realmente en este momento a mí me
gustaría que ustedes pensarán si es
bueno invertir tiempo y dinero en esa
poderosa máquina que es el cuerpo que es
como un templo nosotros somos seres
integrales verdad somos seres que todo
lo que nosotros hacemos se convierte y
todo lo que hacemos y comemos se
convierte así a nivel celular en
nosotros es bueno que te pongas a pensar
por un momentito en cuidar ese cuerpo
que dios el cosmos o la naturaleza lo
que tú creas que te dio
el cuerpo necesita tener un balance un
equilibrio eso toma tiempo no es de un
día para otro
verdad pero lo que yo quiero que ustedes
se lleven o jacques de aquí es déjenme
decirles a una buena noticia que nunca
pero nunca es tarde para empezar así que
por su salud 911 gracias
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]